[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on sockin very
excited to be talking about our public
responsibilities to educate children we
have Carol Kosovar joining us on the
show hello hello thank you for coming on
really appreciate it and it was so nice
first meeting you when we did the panel
on school choice with the Libertarian
Party of San Francisco that was very
nice you were teaching me so much about
the complexity of what actually goes on
for this you know there vouchers there's
charter schools there's public schools
there's how to fund those there's
getting parents informed and involved in
their child's education there's so much
complexity and I was so grateful that we
got to meet and now we get this longer
one-on-one conversation Carol's
background for those that don't know
Carol is the former past president of
the California State PTA she is also a
former journalist and attorney and
Ombudsperson for special education she's
currently the host of looking at
education on ka LW 91.7 FM and also a
writer for ed 100 which is a web
resource for inform parents to inform
parents on how schools systems work and
how to get the children of these of
these these beautiful kids into just
better education this is our public
responsibility to educate children so
let's ask Carolina like a big history
perspective of civilization we find
ourselves as stewards of earth we have
this reproduction cycle where we have
offspring and then we have to educate
the offspring on on the collective
learning and so as we kind of water
these the seeds and figure out exactly
like what nutrients to give them how do
you see that that's that synthesis on
how
best do that well you started with an
easy question right yeah but I think
that every generation has a
responsibility to educate their children
and some of those things are the same
regardless of what generation we are
because we we need to help our kids
understand the world they're living in
we need to give them the skills to
negotiate and navigate how that world
works we have to provide them with a
love and nurturing and understanding
that makes them understand the
importance of education
and I think particularly in the United
States part of public education is our
responsibility to creating and
protecting civics in our democracy and I
think that's that's a very very
important role so when we talk about
education we're not just talking about
you know could you do geometry could you
do algebra did you learn French did you
learn Chinese or or whatever it is we're
talking about giving our children the
skills that they need to be responsible
citizens and that I've always felt that
there are more things that we have to
include in education I've been a huge
supporter of making sure that our kids
get arts because arts are how kids learn
if you if you look at you know a young
child they they automatically move with
music they automatically draw it it
opens their imagination and that's
something that we should make sure
that's included throughout a child's
education so that's sort of a broad
answer to your question
did this the seeds are being molded and
given nutrients into the world and
there's a if to understand the world
that they live in like you were
indicating and then we danced with music
we play with art these are kind of these
natural humanities that we we love and
so enjoy and and when funding gets cut
from those areas we become less human in
some ways and and how long has it been
now for advocating for bettering
education for you do we have a long time
to talk about it well since my since my
kids were in public school in San
Francisco and both of my kids have now
graduated and are you know working in
our self-sufficient so it's been at
least a generation of watching how our
education system had works and and what
are those major components that we need
to continue to be successful I got into
education advocacy in a very simple way
and lots of parents get into it in a
very similar way when my kids were in
elementary school we had a teacher who
was the arts teacher and I thought wow
that's terrific we have an arts teacher
but it turned out that the parents had
to pay for that arts teacher and I said
there's something pretty inequitable and
wrong where one school can have parents
who can reach into their pockets and
there's enough in those pockets to pay
for an arts teacher and other schools
don't have it and we really have to make
sure that we meet the needs of all all
of our children and so that was one of
the things that started me on the
journey in in San Francisco and I became
a very huge advocate for arts education
in our schools and we've done something
terrific in San Francisco and that is
that the city realized its
responsibility to our children and we
now have a portion of the city budget
helps pay for things that a lot of
school districts don't have we have
money that goes to pay for librarians we
have money that goes to pay for physical
education we have money that goes to pay
for the arts and that's because we have
I believe a very very responsible
citizenry in in San Francisco where they
they recognize that there's not just the
public schools in the city it's it's all
of us together looking out for children
and we when we talk about the education
of our children we can't forget what are
the life circumstances of our children
so is the child in foster care does the
child is it a child a learner of a
second language does the child have a
home what are the health circumstances
of a child and so we have to roll in all
of our community to make sure that we
meet the needs of a child
I'm very just you're highlighting
something that's so so important all of
the variables that go into the the seed
in because there may not be uh both
parents present there may only be one
parent present there may be no parents
present there may be some sort of other
trauma or some sort of of drug use in
the family or whatever it may be that is
causing some sort of trauma on the on
the child's life in the community is
again helping provide resources for you
know libraries arts the things that are
gonna help make sure that the the seed
gets the right nutrients and so this is
is so so important that you know it's
also good that you actually had you know
like you said a whole generation of
working with your children going through
the San Francisco Public Schools and
being able to kind of pick apart and and
help better the education system now you
know as you're doing that you know
that's kind of like a bid on this this
this importance of or
childhood education and you can probably
speak more to this as I asked this
question but the what were those key
things that you found in bettering
education that we're kind of you know
missing you've started pointing at you
know humanities the arts the libraries
the different SES socio-economic
statuses right well I think you
mentioned something that's more and more
people recognized as important and that
is making sure that our children not
only who are like three four and five
but making sure that our children birth
to five have the supports that they need
to be successful we talk a lot about
something called the achievement gap and
I look at it really as an opportunity
gap because if a child doesn't have the
opportunity to learn and work with
others in a preschool if a child doesn't
have parents who have the experience of
talking and and reading to a child there
are certain things that that we know
help children and if the children don't
have it it's not the child's fault the
child is not a deficit in any way it's
art failure to help that child and so
when we look at the highly successful
school systems in the nation they've put
money into early childhood education
they've put money into making sure our
three and four-year-olds have the the
experiences that they need and so we
have to look at the whole continuum of
Education education doesn't start at
kindergarten yeah and and the one of the
things that that always bothers me
doesn't end at college it doesn't end at
college either but one of the things
that always bothers me is how do people
measure how successful a school is
and some people measure how successful a
school is just on test scores test
scores so the kids doing well and test
scores but there's been a lot of
research about in California and schools
that serve low-income children English
language learners those schools actually
in terms of helping a child move a whole
grade level are more successful than the
high achieving schools because I believe
that if you have moved a child more than
a year in a year wow that is fantastic
but if you're just going year-to-year
that's not as much success and so we
have a lot of schools in California who
are actually doing that yeoman's work of
really helping our kids and this is you
know we also briefly talked about this
before the show as well but it's very
exciting to see the new sort of like
Montessori come up and the new like.we
grows and all these different even like
wilderness schools that are you know
coming into play and it just it seems as
though that the period between this
early childhood neuroscience indicates
that if you do have some sort of traumas
and your family's from even you know 0
to 6 months of age that you're that it's
gonna have some long-term effects that
society is we're gonna have to deal with
so it's also a philosophy of just
informing adults like just don't have
like out of not even wedlock but out of
whatever civil union are out of planned
birth and and because that can lead to
significant traumas with with children
make sure that you're financially able
that you're mentally able that exactly
you're emotionally able your time able
all that kind of stuff
and then and then we you know this is
this is only what we're talking about
with like early childhood Sufis and arts
and humanities this is like this is part
of the equation and then the other part
of like I guess in a sense right now how
we fund schools is property tax wealth
property tax and there's in some states
the state uses their personal income tax
so it's it's a combination but you've
hit on something and I think that we're
at a tipping point in in public
education because if you look at what's
been happening around the nation we have
had teachers standing up and saying we
can't we can't do this anymore and it's
not just about teachers not being paid
enough and they aren't paid enough so
true but it is also about making sure
that they have the support that they
need for the kids making sure that
there's small class size making sure
that their counselors asking for nurses
providing all the things that the school
districts and states that are have a lot
of money are providing for our kids and
so what I see happening in California
you know we've had this in Los Angeles
we're having in Oakland I I would
anticipate that we're going to be seeing
more and more of these issues about
funding and it really talks to and when
I we talk about our responsibility to
our children is the state investing what
it should be investing for our kids so
if we look at California for example and
you talked about property taxes and
we'll get a little wonky but essentially
what happens is they've tried to make it
so that all of the school districts get
a base amount regardless of whether or
not they're able to raise a lot or a
little bit
in property taxes because if they're not
able to raise much the state fills it in
so we have a base amount of money that
all schools get and that helps fill the
holes like if there's not enough funding
for arts and humanities then that can
fill well almost almost if the base
amount isn't enough but the other thing
that we've done is we've moved to a
system where we give more money to
school districts that have children with
higher needs so if you have a lot of
kids who are in poverty if you have a
lot of kids who are English learners if
you have kids who are in foster care
those kids generate more money for their
school district because we know those
kids require more services and I think
that's a very smart thing to do but
regardless of how smart we are in how we
divvy up the pie the pie in California
is too small so for education for
education well you could argue you know
it may not be large enough for
healthcare services and other things too
but let's just talk for a moment about
education so where are we in California
compared to the rest of the nation we've
had a lot of studies and you know we're
about 41st 42nd 43rd in the nation
depending on what study you look at but
41st 42nd 43rd in the nation is way
below the top ten states in the nation
but this is also a population of 40
million people that's right but we have
40 million people but we have to serve
every individual child just because you
live in a state that has a lot of kids
doesn't mean your kids get less they
deserve the same level of education as a
1 million person yeah and so when we
when we look at California and were 41st
in the nation
it would take about thirty five billion
dollars more damn every year thirty-five
billion dollars more every year to get
us to the highest performing States and
so by any measure we're not serving our
children well we're the measure if we if
we measure for example just how much
money we invest well if you don't invest
enough money it means you have the
largest class size in the nation if you
don't invest you're enough money you
have the fewest counselors if you don't
invest enough money you have the fewest
nurses if you don't invest enough money
you have what we're seeing all over
California and that teachers can't
afford to live in the communities where
they're teaching yeah yeah so so if you
neither can the police officers
firefighters or health care yeah right
yeah so so if you compare it used to be
that teaching was a pretty stable strong
middle-class job and then over the years
what we've seen because of diminished
funding and teachers being laid off it's
not viewed of as a stable job we've had
a couple of other things that have
affected teaching years and years ago
for very bright women teaching was where
you went there were not other
opportunities and now women who are the
traditional people who are our teaching
force have a lot more opportunities and
those opportunities pay a lot more money
so if you looked at how much a teacher
pays compared to someone who has equal
education teachers are significantly
below people who have equal education
and that's counting their health
services that's counting their pensions
they are below what others
earn so if you're looking at well will I
go into teaching oh my gosh you know
yeah
the decisions very quickly I can't
afford to live in the metro area where
I'm teaching I this becomes Marija Lee
be dedicated and wanting to help
children to want to become teacher and
the incentives incentive systems are
such an important part of this you know
initially you mentioned this importance
of like you know having 35 billion more
dollars per year in order to be able to
properly educate the children in the
state of California and you know what
that could actually unleash would be
very very very fascinating it's the
difference like you were indicating
between a 30 student class size with one
teacher versus a 10 student class we're
actually talking about class sizes that
maybe in the 40s compared to class sizes
all the research tells us that the the
best class size for k23 is about 18 kids
18 - 18 kids and so our class size you
know people today think they're lucky
their class size is 28 and 30 that's not
small class size oh we're going to bring
our class size down to 25 that is not
small class size if you look at the
research where the kids get the
individual attention that they need 18
is about a really good class size so you
know people have forgotten what it what
it looks like in California we have lots
of teachers who come in who have never
for example experienced having Arts in
the schools because they grew up in a
time when our schools didn't have arts
and so they're not used to doing that so
we have a lot of work to do in terms of
helping our teachers being prepared to
provide those services yes and then this
also kind of for me brings up this
this question again where we kind of
started on this point just about the
complexity of how the schools work
there's public school options there's a
private school options there's charter
school options there's the school
vouchers there's the the so so this is
very accomplished lottery systems right
so the lottery system in San Francisco
was because we were trying to make it so
that the low SES and high SES weren't so
drastically separated and we're trying
to give more opportunities to low SES a
voucher system you could get a part of
the of the school's tuition compensated
through a government to allow voucher
but you're against vouchers and and then
so then how does how does all that
complicated like informing the parents
so that they also can understand what
the best decisions are well I have a
pretty strong philosophy that public
money should pay for public schools and
that means that vouchers pseudo vouchers
like tax credits where you use public
money to pay for private schools and
religious schools all of those things I
don't believe go to support a robust
strong public education and we've gone
through over the last several years a
whole effort by lots of forces that have
essentially taken money away from public
education so not only are we not funding
public education in California at the
level that we should but there are also
forces that take money away from the
existing pie that we have now I'm not
saying that we shouldn't have a charter
school that's created in your community
that beats the needs within your
community but I have really serious
issues about large companies coming in
and making a profit
out of and using public money money to
pay for it and these are people who have
essentially in many ways no experience
in running education they may have
experience in making profits but their
experience and expertise is not in
helping kids succeed in education
interesting this is like taking the
public money of the voucher and giving
it to a private organization private
school charter school
well charter school is in some ways a
public school it gets public money good
when you look at vouchers one of the
things about vouchers is that the school
gets to choose who goes to that school a
private school gets to choose who goes
to that school not everyone can get into
that school yeah yeah so you know so
what it's a false premise that it's a
choice it's not the parents choice it's
the choice of that private or religious
school as to who will go there but let's
put boughs aside or and choice aside it
needs to give a ballpark estimate some
of these schools in San Francisco are
like twenty five thousand dollars even
more for you know private schools are
very expensive
but I think we when we talk about
education we really know in our hearts
what our kids need mm-hmm but it is
making sure that we have as you talked
about the seeds making sure that our
schools have all of those ingredients
ingredients to make the seed sprout and
blossom right and so let's talk about
what are those things yes that make a
successful school yeah it's well trained
teachers it's well supported
administrators and superintendents
it's people who have the expertise in
how to help all of our children it's
making sure that nurturing and
supporting is at the basis of our
philosophy of education it's education
is not a race to the top education is
about meeting the needs of the child who
walks into your classroom and figuring
out how to help that child yet the the
one of the ways that you know we were
chatting about about looking at it was
yeah a big race to for test scores a big
race to have to fill in bubbles and um
how can a child possibly be asked to
comprehend critical thinking skills when
they have when they're malnourished or
mouth sheltered or you don't have the
love and compassion from a parent in
their lives so we he'd there's the
ingredients have to be there for the sea
to be able to blossom in an educational
some plus the child's were kind of in US
and also in a sense pushing all children
through the same assembly line of of
language and history and math and
science and this is of course these are
important fields but there is also a for
the child to be exposed to what they
most enjoy and then for the child to be
able to engage what they most enjoy at a
young age over and over and practice and
mold and create and and do that process
from a very young age can help them
become that artist or entrepreneur down
the down their life faster then if they
could only start that when they're 20
three and they're and they're out of the
collegiate system and then they're like
$200,000 in debt I don't even know what
I love doing that's a disaster for
education and there's a lot of
for-profit greed and gluttony that is
also advocating for not changing the
system from so I'd like to talk a little
bit we've talked about some of the
ingredients yes of making sure that we
have a warm nurturing environment and
and teachers who are well paid well
trained but we also have another
component right we have parents yes and
so we have had a oh I think a wonderful
transition in our demographics of
California because we have now the rich
robust cultures of people from around
the world who may not have had the
experience of public education in
California or may not have graduated
from a high school here and so how do we
help those parents understand how the
system works
so that they know what what does the
research say you know I talked to you
about what the research is on class size
but what what does the research say and
our system here in California
as a system where our whole community
tries to make decisions on what's best
for our kids so we need to make sure
that our parents understand the
education system why are the arts
important
what are your opportunities for various
things and so I'd like to switch a
little bit to something called IDI 100
which is a an online resource that I've
helped create with a with Jeff camp who
is the tech guy and sort of the
mastermind behind it but I've been
working on it trying to help parents
understand how the system works so they
can stand up and be confident
spokespeople
for their kids and this is a this is an
interesting way to to take a look at
things because you have this you know
short plainly worded lessons explain how
California school system really works
this is as though you are taking and
compacting or compressing down the
important wisdoms from how the systems
work in order to have the parents become
more informed right and what usually
when people talk about education
education is full of jargon IEP SST all
of these things lcff El Cap you have
what I saw those those right and and
people are like oh my gosh what the heck
are you talking about and they have two
jobs and it's right there kids so this
is written in in short easy lessons so
that and we try to make it fun too
little humor in it so that you can spend
a little bit of time learning about
something and so we we have lessons
remember we were talking about school
finance well you know you could have an
encyclopedia about how school finance
works in California well we have a
chapter that has
ten lessons where if you go through
those lessons you will understand how
school finance works in California and
we also have a chapter for example of
what's the right stuff what what should
our school have and it talks about the
importance of the Arts yes
talks about social emotional learning
yes talks about you know literacy talks
about math talks about special education
yeah yeah and then that way the as the
parent becomes more informed they can
also identify that and potentially the
school lacks one of these areas that
that we need a that we need to address
or that I can better understand the the
process of how schools actually get that
the the funding dollars they need other
teachers do what would what would be a
good way for you know this is ed 100 org
for those in the links in the bio for
those that want to to check it out and
this is for California school system and
this could also potentially go to like
New York school system it says that
finance part is about California okay
but most of the other lessons you know
anyone can can pick them up and and read
them and understand them that's great
yes because then that becomes applicable
to everybody on what should be the
socio-emotional etc in the schools now
in terms of how to you know in order to
have the you know inform teachers in
order to have the the properly funded
teachers and administrators and all
these components like like these modules
that you're talking about for school how
does the how does the one get the
increase in funding to be able to afford
that
I think one of the things that you have
to do is create informed parents who
will speak up and speak out about what's
happening in our schools it it doesn't
happen without a force a crisis creates
change and I think if you look at what's
happening in California we have reached
a crisis level in terms of funding our
schools we would not have teachers
striking in communities throughout
California and communities throughout
the nation if we hadn't reached a sort
of tipping point in saying look guys one
of our most basic responsibilities as
citizens is to educate our children and
we've gone through a sort of a huge
economic shift in our nation where we
have some people who have gobs of money
but lots of people who don't have a lot
of money and we we have to stand up and
say regardless of whether you're you
know a multi-millionaire for someone who
has just come to the California and
doesn't speak English we have a
responsibility to educate all of our
children and meet the needs of all of
our children and so we have to speak up
and speak out and it is unending
pressure on our elected officials that
has them look in the face of our
children and look in the face of our to
our teachers and ask them are we doing
the right thing one of the things that
elected officials are afraid of it's a
three letter word and it's called tax
tax
it's called tax yeah and we have to get
past that because we will not we will
not
reach and meet the needs of our children
you know unless we all chip in and all
creates more issues when the children
don't have the needs met in the
communities that creates more issues
yeah yeah all chipping in Ron I wanna
hear your hear your thoughts on crisis
creates change I know you like that
phrase I really have you know no comment
because you know educating children you
know it goes it always goes back to the
parents because there's parents that
believe in some stuff that may not be in
the developing child's best interest but
they want to instill these beliefs these
things that they believe are true but
may not necessarily be so that that's
problematic in itself but the
institution of Education you know there
there has been a system where you know
that the rich and the poor you know we
need poor people we don't want to
educate creative children we want to
just create obedient workers so we have
to just move on from that system and
there's something also in charge of that
that's well aware of what they're doing
so it's I'm kind of hard-pressed
homeschooling is an option for a lot of
people these days I hear too but those
those homeschoolers are the parents that
I was talking about earlier the parents
that believe in crazy stuff and
and I don't want to get too deep into
that well that's one of the reasons and
it's not just to address crazy stuff but
that's one of the reasons we created ed
100 so that parents could have a place
to go that's reliable trustworthy yeah
real facts and compress and compressor
and where there's a you know this side
and of that side we put in the research
for this side and of that side but if if
there's any sense of telling people a
point of view it's making sure that
people understand what the funding is
like and what our children are missing
by having a funding system here in
California that that is inadequate and
it's not just if you it's not just you
look at the numbers I mean if if if your
kids are getting half as much as kids in
other states that would be okay if your
kids were doing well right but if we
look at national statistics about how
well our kids are doing compared to kids
who are in wealth funded education
systems they're not doing well they're
not doing well and so we have this
combination of kids not having the
supports that they need and as a result
not doing as well as we would hope that
they could do and it's research I mean
we have to look at at the research and
what what do we know helps our kids this
is a
good segue into talking about sleep and
talking about later start times you know
what is the literature saying about
about having are you guys also sending
parents the compressed I these
compressed ideas that get your kids to
sleep get them to sleep there
seven hours that they need in there
actually high school kids need about
nine and is it nine thirty nine for
youth and then it goes down to eight is
for adults so there's been a tremendous
amount of research in the last couple of
years about the importance of sleep
particularly for middle and high school
kids and the research is so profound
that kids need more sleep that the
American Academy of Pediatrics and the
Centers for Disease Control have looked
at those adolescents and said hold it a
second these kids are not getting enough
sleep and they're recommending that
middle and high schools not start before
8:30 in the morning yeah because if
there's a whole lot of science behind it
but essentially their bodies change when
they get into adolescence and they stay
up late until 11 o'clock at night they
can't fall asleep you can tell them go
to sleep fall asleep but their bodies
don't let them fall asleep and so
there's a big push which I support
wholeheartedly of making sure that our
kids get enough sleep and that's one of
the things we should follow follow the
science follow the research when we have
this overwhelming research that says if
kids don't get enough sleep they don't
do well in school they have emotional
depressive challenges they they get into
car accidents because they're drowsy
there are whole bunches of reasons why
and they fall asleep in class right now
the information overload comes
from the devices that are right by their
bedside so when they wake up and when
they go to sleep and then that also
prevents a lot of not only sleep at
night but also wake up in the morning
and not even giving the brain the space
to creatively just be in the space that
they're in but it's immediately going on
to online and what percentage of those
conversations that are happening online
are actually meaningful are actually
intellectually stimulating versus just
keeping a streak right it was just a
study in Seattle where they moved their
time back in their middle and high
schools and they could document it that
the kids do better and in California
there's a big movement there's a bill
it's SB 328 which is saying you know
let's look at the science let's make
sure that all of our kids have the
opportunity to go to school at a time
that meets their physical needs yeah and
however it can also be best for working
parents to be able to pass time with
their kids in the evenings as well and
get them get their kids in in the
mornings and this is this has been
extremely wide-ranging I think maybe
another important piece just to just
attack Balan at the end is III I'm
really starting to feel that there may
be some sort of a bifurcation happening
in the education of children in the
sense of things like Montessori schools
things like you know we grow wheeze new
weworks new programs just this it seems
as though that these new styles of of
they're kind of old they're old styles
that are being rebirthed really in in
educating children and it seems to me
that that if it's if it's going to be
socioeconomically not
feasible that it's this is a difficult
thing for us to deal with well well
there's a huge push and they have all
these words they call it
social-emotional learning they call it
whole child but it is about meeting the
child where the child is and providing
the child with community resources when
the child needs community resources you
talk about Montessori - Ori is a very
old historic way of teaching my
experience with - Tori's might my son
went to Montessori he thrived in it I
thought it was a wonderful preschool
environment where where kids get to
decide what's important they can do
independent things it's a it's a
wonderful way of responding to how young
children learn and this feels translate
for the rest of their life and as we
started out is the skills that we're
looking for in our graduates you know
when these tech companies look at who
they're gonna hire they don't just look
at what their test scores are totally
they look to see do they take art did
they take music yeah are they innovative
how do they think yes and the other
thing you know that that people look for
is do play well of others if you play
well you play well with the library and
so when we when we talk about social
emotional learning we talk about
community schools that's really the
those important things that that were
we're trying to get our children to be
able to respond well so they can be
responsible citizens in a democracy yeah
this is why you're a major proponent for
civics and for getting young kids on the
social-emotional train as well
especially as we enter the age of
Exponential's and we see more and more
robotics and artificial intelligence
come in that there is a greater and
greater need for the the
social-emotional know skills as well
there's one other thing that I can add I
don't know how much time we have left
yeah I have a couple quick questions on
the way I'll go but one of the things
that I think is very important and it
talks about building responsibilities is
having kids have lessons and work in the
community that ties yes to their lessons
people call it service-learning that's
good but it is the opportunity to
connect what you're learning in school
with what's happening in the outside
world whether you're learning something
in biology and you go to garden you do
some gardens and also making that
connection to political voice yeah and
so knowing that it's not just biology
but if it's not working well in your
community having the confidence to speak
up and say you know what we're not quite
doing it right I'd like to get involved
I think a lot of that Socratic dialogue
that happens between young kids and you
know we just had a Michael strong from
the Academy of thought an industry on
the show and we really like that sort of
idea of just a dialogue that happens
between kids on a specific topic and
then they get to engage the teacher
maybe once a week ask a question get
back to like talking about ideas and how
they would build these ideas and I think
like you said translating the
conversations into community work and
and when I'm learning how to make that
change okay let's just do the quick
couple questions on the way out this is
simulation so we must ask you are we in
a simulation
[Music]
no this is real life this is what this
is the most important thing that we do
and that is educating our children it's
not a simulation this is the real thing
and we've got to get it right then no
matter what we must get it right
absolutely that's the truth now and we
may even be tested on how well we can
get this right and it might it may not
be fill in the blanks either yeah that's
right and our last question is what do
you think's the most beautiful thing in
the world oh my goodness besides sunsets
I think and this is this is like from a
mother right I think the most beautiful
thing in the world is the first time you
see your baby smile mmm yeah there is
something very precious about what's
going on in that and the child's
energy field what when their first
extreme me smile you're looking at their
eyes it's so precious but I'm not I'm
not gonna talk about how wonderful my
grandchildren are but oh yeah
grandchildren too now you've had another
round of seeing the smiles oh that's
lucky yeah yeah yeah yeah
San Francisco is I also had this very
strange vision that it could potentially
be that like San Francisco gets so
populated with like 20 to 30 year-olds
that that don't have kids that the
schools just disappear from the San
Francisco area but I think the one the
one thing about San Francisco is it's in
our DNA to do the right thing and we
have had a history of making sure that
we step in and try to help our community
it's a we're a very very democratic City
and people are not we there's a lot of
given political give-and-take but the
heart of San Francisco really is in the
right place with very well secured oh
thank you so much for coming on at the
show and talking to us this has been
such a pleasure my pleasure thank you
yeah there's so much to still understand
and unpack about how to best take on
this responsibility of educating
children into our world and all the
complex nuance that goes into it all
these modules that need to be involved
and engaged in parenting and be engaged
and informed everyone check out the
links in the bio to ed 100 as well as
Carol's other work go and check that out
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
we greatly appreciate you we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
go and get talking in your communities
about how to best educate how to best
nurture the minds that are being born
into our world today shout out to Ron
Vargas for producing and directing thank
you very much we love you thank you
thank you and go and build everyone
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in around the world go
and support them and
[Music]
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you so
much and we will see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]